AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> MEDIA DARLING AND AMERICA'S
TOP DOCTOR DR. FAUCI IS PLAYING
DENSE AFTER A TROUGH OF EMAILS
BLEW A HOLE IN HIS SHRINKING
CREDIBILITY.
THEY REVEALED HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE WUHAN LAB FACING
SCRUTINY IN THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT KILLED MILLIONS.
SENATOR RAND PAUL SAID FAUCI
LIED ABOUT THAT LAB THAT COULD
MAKE VIRUSS MORE DEADLY.
>> IN PRIVATE EMAILS HE PUT IN
THE SUBJECT LINE, URGENT, WE
MUST DISCUSS GIANNULLI.
-- THIS GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
IT WAS SO NAIVE WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE DR. FAUCI IN A POSITION OF
ADVICING THE U.S. OR WORLD OR
ANYBODY ELSE.
>> DR. FAUCI REFUSES TO CALL OUT
CHINA.
>> THE IDEA I THINK IS QUITE
FARFETCHED THAT THE CHINESE
DELIBERATELY ENGINEERED
SOMETHING TO KILL THEMSELVES AND
OTHER PEOPLE.
OBVIOUSLY YOU WANT OPENNESS AND
COOPERATION.
ONE OF THE WAYS CAN YOU GET IS
DON'T BE ACCUSATORY.
>> AND THE WHITE HOUSE IS
STANDING BY FAUCI DESPITE THE
EMAIL CONTROVERSY.
>> WE WILL LET HIM SPEAK FOR
HIMSELF.
HE'S BEEN AN ASSET IN OUR
COUNTRY PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
>> JESSE, DON'T BE ACCUSATORY.
>> HE SHOULD HAVE HAD A SECRET
SERVER IN HIS BASEMENT AND HE
COULD HAVE WIPED IT.
THESE EMAILS ARE BAD.
HE IS ON THE RECORD SUPPORTING
GAIN OF FUNCTION IN WUHAN.
THIS THING LOOKED ENGINEERED AND
HE IS ON EMAIL SCRAMBLING.
"VANITY FAIR" BLEW THE LID OFF
THE COVER-UP.
U.S. GOVERNMENT TELLING
INVESTIGATORS DON'T LOOK INTO
THIS BECAUSE U.S. MONEY WENT
INTO THIS LAB.
MANPOWER.
KNOW HOW.
MONEY.
WENT INTO THIS LAB THAT ENDED UP
KILLING 3.5 MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN 9-11 ANDING
ABOUT THAN JANUARY 6TH.
THIS MIGHT BE WORSE.
>> AND WATERGATE.
>> AND THE MEDIA IS COMPLICIT IN
THE COVER-UP.
THE DEMOCRATS NEEDED FAUCI TO
BRAND THEMSELVES AS PRO-SCIENCE.
THEY NEEDED FAUCI TO LOCK
EVERYTHING DOWN SO THEY COULD
LOOSEN STATE ELECTION LAWS AND
DO MAIL-IN BALLOTS AND THEY
NEEDED FAUCI TO POINT THE FINGER
AWAY FROM CHINA AND AT TRUMP TO
DIVIDE THE COUNTRY FOR THE
ELECTION.
YOU TAKE FAUCI OUT OF THE
PICTURE IT'S LIKE TAKING A BLOCK
OUT, THE WHOLE THING CRUMBLES.
>> WILL THEY GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT, BIDEN?
>> I THINK THEY WILL.
THE FACT WE HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM
THE W.H.O. LOOKED INTO IT INTO
WE ARE LOOK INTO OURSELVES AND
THERE IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I SO NO REASON WHY PRESIDENT
BIDEN WOULD STOP.
THAT.
HILLARY IS NOT EVEN HILLARY.
NOW SHE IS JUST CROOKED.
>> YES.
>> SECOND OF ALL, YOU SAID THAT
THE WHOLE TOWER FALLS WHICH
INCLUDED THE MAIL-IN BALLOTS.
YOU ARE ALLEGING THE ELECTION
WAS FRAUDULENT?
>> NO, IT HELPED LOOSEN THE
STATE ELECTION LAWS BECAUSE
EVERYBODY HAD TO STAY HOME
DURING THE LOCKED.
YOU DO NOT NEED TO LOCK
EVERYBODY DOWN.
FAUCI WAS WARNED TO DO THIS BY
SCIENTISTS.
WE SAW THE EMAILS AND HE IGNORED
IT.
>> DR. WATERS SPOKE ON THAT.
>> YES, HE HAS.
FROM LOOKING AT THE EMAILS.
THINK SOME DOESN'T LOOK
FANTASTIC.
HE WAS WITH JOHN BERMAN AND HE
CLARIFIED IF THEY HAD KNOWN WHAT
THEY KNEW IN APRIL AND MAY HE
WOULD HAVE TOLD PEOPLE TO WEAR
A MASK ON THE FLIGHT.
WE WERE GETTING NEW INFORMATION
FROM THE SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY AS
IT WENT ALONG.
>> SCIENCE WAS NOT SETTLED?
>> NO.
>> LIKE GLOBAL WARMING IS NOT
SETTLED?
>> NO, IT'S SETTLED.
>> ON THE SURFACE THE MOST
REASON EXPLANATION WAS THERE IS
A VIROLOGY LAB RIGHT IN WUHAN
WHILE THE BATS LIVED IN CAVES
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY.
THE MEDIA AND DR. FAUCI BENT
OVER BACKWARDS TO LEAN ON
A HYPOTHESIS THAT WAS NOT
LOGICAL AS IT CAME OUT OF A LAB
THAT HAD SAFETY PROBLEMS BECAUSE
PING TALKED ABOUT IT.
>> THIS "VANITY FAIR" ARTICLE,
IT MADE EXPLOSIVE ALLEGATIONS.
PEOPLE IN THE STATE DEPARTMENT
WERE TELLING PEOPLE SHUT IT
DOWN.
DON'T GO THERE BECAUSE YOU WILL
OPEN A PANDORA'S BOX.
DR. FAUCI SAID WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL WITH CHINA BECAUSE WE
NEED TO COOPERATE WITH THEM.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN TRANSPARENT
WITH THE W.H.O. OR ANYONE ELSE.
YOU GET MORE FLIES WITH HONEY
BUT WHEN THEY COMMIT HUMAN
RIGHTS ATROCITIES IT'S TIME TO
GET WITH THE HONEY AND GO WITH
SOMETHING STRONGER.
>> THE COMMUNIST PARTY BRAGGED
IF THEY ARE TALKING AND
BREATHING THEY ARE LYING.
>> THE FUNNEST PART IS THEY
MENTIONED THE PHRASE PANDORA'S
BOX.
THAT LAB IS ONE.
THEY OPENED IT AND IT GOT OUT.
I WONDER HOW MANY INVESTIGATIONS
ARE STOPPED WHEN SOMEONE SAYS
THAT'S A PANDORA'S BOX.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD OPEN THE BOX TO
SEE WHAT IS GOING ON.
ONE OF THE REASONS THEY WANTED
TO BLAME THE WET MARKETS IT'S
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF THE LAB.
IT'S BECAUSE WE ARE INVOLVED IN
THE LAB.
WE HAVE MONEY THERE.
WE WERE THINKING IT'S THE
CHINESE.
NO, WE ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
OURSELVES.
THESE ARE OUR EXPERTS AND OUR
SCIENTISTS.
CONSIDER IF THERE WERE THE PLOT
TO A MOVIE.
SCIENTISTS IN GOVERNMENT ENGAGE
CONTROVERSIAL AND RISKY
RESEARCH.
TWO, THERE IS AN ACCIDENT.
NOBODY IS SAYING THIS WAS
DELIBERATE.
FAUCI BLENDS THAT TOGETHER.
THIS IS UNLEASHED INTO A PUBLIC.
THE SCIENTISTS AND THE
POLITICIANS SCRAMBLE TO PROTECT
THEIR VITAL RESEARCH AND
COVER-UP THE CAUSE.
THAT'S A MOVIE BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S REAL.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN
INVESTIGATION.
IS FAUCI THE VILLAIN?
I THINK HE IS AN OVERLY
DIPLOMATIC BUREAUCRAT.
THE VILLAIN IS THE MEDIA FOR
PUSHING IMPEACHMENT AS THE VIRUS
WAS EXPLODING.
COUNTLESS LIVES WERE LOST
BECAUSE THEY HATED TRUMP.
AND NUMBER TWO LABELLING ANYBODY
A RACIST WHO DARED TO CRITICIZE
CHINA.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A MUSICAL
INSTRUMENT I DON'T WANT TO PLAY
BUT IT HAS SCALES.
>> OH!
I AM LAUGH BUT I AM IN AWE OF
THAT.
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS,
JOE BIDEN AND COMPANY ALL THE
LIBERALS WILL HAVE TO ADMIT
TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
>> YES, THEY CAN'T DO THAT.
THERE IS A LOT OF MONEY AT
STAKE.
YOU CAN'T SUE CHINA IF IT'S THE
LAB.
YOU HAVE TO SUE CHINA AND THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AND THE FUNDING STARTED
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE NEED TO POST-IMPEACH
OBAMA.
>> WE WILL GO TO BREAK AND TALK
ABOUT THE FEASIBILITY OF THAT
HAPPENING.
FIRST I THINK ANY MEDICARE FOR
ALL AND GOVERNMENT RUN
HEALTHCARE IS DEAD.
YOU LOOK AT ANTHONY FAUCI.
WHO WANTS SOME BUREAUCRAT TO
DECIDE WHO GETS TO LIVE AND DIE?
>> PEOPLE WITHOUT INSURANCE
WOULD